بدلا من ان يكتب جملا ومقاطع يحاول تهجئه
احرف وكلمات جديده تماما عليه خالد واحد
من التلاميذ السوريين في الصف الرابع
الابتدائي وجد نفسه فجاه مطالبا بالتعلم
بلغه مختلفه يحاول جاهدا التاقلم معها لكن
ذلك يبدو صعبا ضد المنهج الكردي بس يعني
يبلشوا من الصف الاول يعني ابني هلا يرجع
من المدرسه يعني الانسات المدرسين عم
يدرسون بس يعني
مستوعبه اذا استمر
يعني خليه يقعد بالبيت احسن ما يروح يجيب
مع المدرسه على الفاضي
همم اوكي قرر حكومه اقليم كردستان اعتماد
المناهج الكرديه للمراحل الدراسيه
الاربعاء الاولى والغاء العربيه التي كانت
معتمده في مدارس اللاجئين السوريين اثار
غضب اغلبيه السوريين
القرار كان سريعا وغير مدروس لاسيما وان
اللهجه السرانيه غير مفهومه حتى للمتحدثين
بالكرديه من السوريين القرار الحالي يهدد
مستقبل كامل لذلك نتمنى من الجهه الرسميه
لاعاده النظر بالقرار الذي سيتسبب في تسرب
الطلبه وخلق مشكلات اجتماعيه لاحقا
وزاره التربيه باقليم كردستان العراق تصر
على ان القرار يهدف الى الدمج الاجتماعي
والتعليمي للسوريين وتنكر ان يكون السبب
وقفه دعم الامم المتحده
البلد ولا نريد اي فرق او اختلافات بين
تلاميذ الاقليمي
والقرار مستمر و سيشمل اضافه مرحله في كل
عام
يقيم في اقليم كردستان نحو 250 الف لاجئ
سوري ما زال معظمهم في حكم طالبه اللجوء
وبالتالي فان عودتهم الى سوريا غير
مستبعده وهذا ما يقض مضاجع كثيرين بشان
مستقبل اولادهم وعدم الاعتراف بشهاداتهم
الدراسيه
من تلاميذ اللاجئين السوريين يدفعون اليوم
ضريبه قرار تغيير لغه التعليم ومثلهم اكثر
من الف مدرس قد يحرمون من وظائفهم اذا
استمر تنفيذ قرار يوصف بانه مثير للجدل
حكيم الجزيره اربيل